yo I wonder you went viral a couple of
weeks ago you went on no jumper mhm and
uh Adam asked you what he asked you and
then you just stayed silent yeah which I
feel like should be uh applied more if
you're an artist Who's involved in
certain Lifestyles I feel like most
people just need to shut the [__] up
yeah man a lot of the people could get
on this camera and be trying to make
their s look good tell a story yeah in
there po him up to him up Cho him up do
all type of weak ass gay ass [__] on
camera they homies now they be in jail
de homies you in jail yeah well like
young thug they just came out today
they're actually the trial just started
and they're going to use his lyrics
against them so let alone interviews but
for you like going viral uh with that do
you feel like Adam was trying to like
you know a lot of people say Adam's the
[__] uh what do they call him the
feds no could not the F bro no Adam's a
great guy he's my boy but I just wonder
like like I you you know I always tell
people like uh when they go on Vlad or
when they go on no jumper like yo you
it's up to you how you answer question I
need stop calling C F too CU my boy
invited me to his birthday party too cuz
I'mma see you there yeah what's it next
week right popping up you're pulling up
yeah Jesus Christ pull up cuz the only
thing I'm wor see when when like [__]
like that like cuz Adams like knows so
many gang members yeah I'm like there's
going to be a lot of people the same
already to bro I'm to [__] no Ops [__]
them are me okay and he okay okay so you
know trophy cuz trophy status cuz trophy
no Ops will be in the building hell no
that's that's a great yeah yeah that's
the one thing with like I got I'm going
to Adam's birthday party too so I'll see
you there we she have a good time but
it's funny that that clip went so viral
cuz like you literally just stayed I
thought the [__] video they used to
so many rappers just getting on there
and just talking so much when somebody
do some different [__] it's like oh wow
on game yeah but that's just how that's
what you that's what you just talk
growing up don't say [__] Bro yourself
don't who El that's just normal who's on
Vlad peee long was on Vlad I don't know
if you ever see that clip he was asking
about being a [__] if PE long just
looked at he was just like it's crazy um
for you man like uh talk about like is
there anything that you have noticed you
know since signing your deal since I
guess you've had so much momentum over
the last four or five months but is
there anything that you've noticed and
or learned um about the music game cuz
the music game in the street [__] is
totally different the music business is
the music business it is the music
business keyword is business yeah on the
dead that's what I really learned like
everything really like business it's not
just hit a [__] up hey see me be record
it bam drop it just all right B it's
like way you got get ATI agreement the
it's like steps to this [__] right you
got to get people's publishing
information yeah yeah it's really like
it's really like steps to this [__] so
it's bigger than just like getting the
beats in and just recording it he
shooting a video and dropping it's like
really like real [__] especially now
you're on like an actual label so
everything got to have some sort of
paperwork everything is like paperwork
involved and all that type of [__] so
yeah well some artists will take that
[__] personal cuz they be like wait a
minute we just hanging out the studio
why I got to like yeah like no like this
is just how it goes and it's funny cuz
on the D homies on the D homies couple
people hit me up too that was like M bro
like this what's going on all right
nobody didn't feel like nobody didn't
get B about it though they can't C you
know [__] people get but hurt though
yeah that's that because they [__]
that's fair anybody uh feature that
you're sitting on right now that you've
been working
with yeah I got a I got I got a crazy
feature coming cuz it's crazy though is
it already done yeah who is it you going
to see cuz where they
from LA County LA County that's a that's
a very general they booming they're
booming from LA County top top rank top
rank of course top rank blast no Ry
[__]
no even if C do say the name I'm not
going to
yeah I mean hey hey you rank though this
going to be the one you and blast would
be crazy get blast on a hook that's
[__] out of here yeah blast do got
some fire though blast go crazy I saw
you love R Rodriguez yeah R go crazy
hard I I uhra we had a a very
entertaining fun interview here you
entertaining I mean you interviewed him
yeah it was great it we actually had fun
like he was actually like you know you
know like he you could tell he's not
comfortable being on camera like yeah
he's just like a dude who's famous you
know what I'm saying so we talked about
all kind of wild [__] but I wonder like
uh for you like who who would you
consider to be your biggest influences
on your sound like when I'm listening to
you like who influenced your sound
musically nobody cuz like myself I
really like got my own sound cuz I go in
there and do my own [__] punch in my own
way I influence my own s yeah yeah I do
my own [__] yeah so you feel like I mean
obviously you were listening to Draco
though were you listening to any of the
shoreline [__] yeah but should I yeah uh
yeah I was listening to them two growing
up on games shout Oz yeah Oz and was
going crazy [__] yeah I was listening to
a lot of people growing up cuz just at
that moment like Draco was like the
first one that popped in my head so they
like really like took that and R with it
oh he was listening to Draco oh and
Draco influence n you know wasn't like
my influence it was hard though I listen
to a lot of people growing up but Draco
was just like one of the main like that
whole W like greo Shoreline Draco Draco
like all them Mike sh was like boing
around that time shout out to Mike sh
[__] a classic yeah on G shout out
to the Bay yeah on the dead homies but
like yeah I was listening to them but
like yeah nobody really like influenced
my sound they ain't heard nobody rapping
be like Oh I'm going to start rapping
like this or I want to just do this what
like um do you remember like when did
you first record your first record like
when you when's the first time you like
blad some vocals in Pro Tools or uh 2016
okay so you've been like you've been
kind of when did you would you say you
you finally took this [__] serious once
you got out yeah I took it serious when
I got out like 20 like last year last
year my oldest video my oldest video on
YouTube only say 11 months ago that's
crazy so that was like I'm barely like
I'm barely like fresh bro like on the
homies bro and so did you have the plan
together like yo let I'm getting out and
I'm doing this [__] for real yeah hell
yeah hell yeah and then when I get out
when I got out and then did the [__]
with rimo seen the reaction in the
backlash that guy I'm like okay yeah
shout out to ramble man he's a word
Smith yeah shout out ramble coo crazy
he's [__] hard bro he be having the
most illst like I love his delivery but
his punch lines like his lines be so
[__]
crazy listen to you going to laugh about
three
times she be like yo talking crazy why
didn't I think of that like that was he
said the most basic like relatable [__]
in the flyest way yeah yeah shout out to
ramble yeah for sure we need a ramble
album bro it's been a minute yeah that
song he got with blast uh was it child
of God that shit's hard as [__] sh that
[__] hard uh is Rambo going to be on
your
album probably
probably probably probably I like that I
like that so ramble and then then
another bigger LA County yeah you got to
get with [__] that Mexican o you guys
are label mates yeah probably he's um
he's a superstar man he's he's on his
way have you heard a [__] I heard like a
song or two yeah he's hard and you guys
need to go hog hunting in Texas yeah
yeah yeah it's a lot of [__] cuz that
I'll be interested doing cuz a lot of
people won't even think that I do like
what like [__] bungee jumping cuz I
want to do that [__] I want to [__]
Skydive yeah see that's all type of
little I draw the line on skydiving I
feel like if I'm going to jump out of a
plan Will Smith be making all that [__]
look cool cuz Will Smith does make skyd
look amazing Co make everything look
amazing cuz sh except being with j p
Smith that does not look amazing yeah C
bunk for that but I'm talking about like
like travel life oh he's doing all the
cool adventure [__] travel life cuz make
everything look fun you be like what the
[__] I want to go right here oh yeah his
IG is wild but yeah that yeah she she
she bunk run cuz yeah homie she bunk
yeah yeah she's just out here doing
[__] interviews doing she getting hit
she she trash she getting the August
alcena on the side yes shout out to Jada
a very stressful relationship I'm sure
to be a part of shout out to Will Smith
who's a better man than I am I'll say
that